♪
>> Tucker: WELL ON THIS SHOW
OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE KEPT
YOU CONSISTENTLY INFORMED OF
ANY WEIRD ACTIVITY IN THE
SKIES ABOVE US.
MOST SHOWS DO NOT DO THAT
THEY ARE TOO EMBARRASSED BUT
WE ARE NOT.
WHY WOULD WE BE.
IF ALIEN LIFE EXISTS IT IS
MORE LIKE WE WILL HEAR FROM
IT BEFORE WE SEE IT A ITEM
SCOPE IN CANADA REPORTS
PICKING UP A STRANGE
POWERFUL SIGNAL FROM FAR,
FAR AWAY.
WHAT IS IT EXACTLY.
BRETT LARSON HAS BEEN
LOOKING INTO IT FOR US HE IS
FOX NEWS HEADLINES 24/7 ON
SIRIUS XM AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT WITH MORE.
>> THIS IS DEFINITELY ONE OF
THOSE WHAT KIND OF STORIES.
THIS IS SOMETHING CALLED A
FAST RADIO BURST.
IT WAS DETECTED MULTIPLE
TIMES AND HAS MANY
SCIENTISTS SAYING WE NEED
MORE DATA.
SO A COUPLE THINGS CAN BE A
FAST RADIO BURST.
IT COULD BE A NEUTRON STAR
WITH A STRONG MAGNETIC
FIELD.
TWO NEW TRON STARS COLLIDING
A BLACK HOLE, PERHAPS, AND
YES COULD ACTUALLY BE AN
ALIEN.
LATEST DISCOVERY COMES
ALMOST BY CHANCE FROM
SOMETHING CALLED CHIME, IT'S
THE CANADIAN HYDROGEN
INTENSITY MAPPING
EXPERIMENTING.
THE SYSTEM WASN'T EVEN
COMPLETELY SET UP WHEN THEY
DISCOVERED THE BURST.
NOW THE FAST RADIO BURST
FOUND ARE FROM A GALAXY
VERY, VERY FAR AWAY.
ONE AND A HALF BILLION LIGHT
YEARS TO BE EXACT.
IT IS JUST THE SECOND TIME
THAT A REPEAT OF A FAST
RADIO BURST HAS BEEN
DETECTED.
AND THE OBJECT CHIME FOUND
PRODUCED ACTUALLY 6
DIFFERENT BURST.
ARROW TECHNICAL REPORTS THAT
THE DOZENS OF FAST RADIO
BURSTS IDENTIFIED ONLY ONE
OTHER HAS PRODUCED MULTIPLE
BURSTS.
THIS IS ACTUALLY KIND OF
SIGNIFICANT.
MORE AND MORE SCIENTISTS ARE
LOOKING INTO THE SKIES WITH
MORE PRECISE INSTRUMENTS TO
FIND THESE SIGNALS AND THEY
DON'T LAST FOR VERY LONG.
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING YOU ARE
GOING TO HEAR.
LIKE A FRACTION OF A SECOND.
AND IT SHOWS UP ON A GRAPH.
SOME ASTRONOMERS HAVE
CONSIDERED THE IDEA THAT
THESE BURSTS CAN BE FROM
INTELLIGENT LIFE ELSEWHERE
AND WITH MORE SCIENTISTS
SEARCHING FOR THEM WE WILL
LIKELY FIND OUT MORE ABOUT
THEM AND FIND MORE OF THEM.
I THINK IT'S ALIEN.
I'M GOING TO GO OUT ON A
LIMB AND SAY I THINK IT'S
ALIEN.
AND I THINK IT'S FASCINATING
THAT YOU POINT A RADIO
RECEIVER TO THE SKY AND WE
PICK UP RADIO SIGNALS.
GRANTED, THERE ARE
SCIENTIFIC EXPLANATIONS FOR
IT.
>> Tucker: SO, TO FLIP IT
AROUND.
I WANT TO BE SURE I
UNDERSTAND.
THIS NOTHING ABOUT IT THAT I
REALLY UNDERSTAND.
THERE IS NO HARD CONSENSUS
THAT THIS IS A NATURALLY
OCCURRING FEN NUMB?
THERE ARE SERIOUS SCIENTISTS
WHO BELIEVE THIS COULD BE AN
INTENTIONAL ACT, THE SENDING
OF THESE RADIO SIGNALS.
>> IT COULD BE -- IT COULD
BE FROM THE COLLAPSE OF A
PLANET.
IT COULD BE SIGNALS THAT
COME OUT OF A BLACK HOLE.
AND IF IT IS SIGNALS THAT
COME OUT OF A BLACK HOLE,
THAT'S AWESOME, TOO.
BECAUSE WE CAN THEN LEARN
MORE ABOUT THEM.
IT COULD BE A NEUTRON STAR
IT COULD BE TWO OF THEM
COLLIDING.
AGAIN, THAT'S ALSO A VERY
COOL THING THAT WE CAUGHT
IT.
WE CAN NOW HEAR THE
SIGNATURE THAT IT MAKES WHEN
THESE THINGS HAPPEN IN THE
SKIES ABOVE US.
AND THE GALAXY IS LITERALLY
BEYOND THE MILL CAN I WAY.
MILKY WAY.
IF IT'S ALIEN GET JODY
FOSTER.
BUILD A SPACESHIP AND SEND
HER.